so this was the first animation ever
look at this shot it's just stunningly
animated wow look at all that detail
work
you know you can see some cheats here
big thanks to puget systems for
sponsoring today's episode all right
guys welcome back just kidding this is
the first of its kind
it's animators react and we have eric
koenig with us today
he's a master he's been doing it since
the 90s what have you worked on that
people would know well i went to
school at a great place called cal arts
and then i got right in the animation
industry worked with a guy named chuck
jones a very famous warner brothers
animator
i worked on a movie called cats don't
dance then went to
disney dreamworks and then for the last
13 or 14 years i've been on the simpsons
have you drawn yourself into the
simpsons as a character i am
in the simpsons movie really yes what do
i do i don't know what to do
because if i say i'm trapped if i leave
i'm alone oh god in
out in out i never saw venice
we love anime we love you know old
disney movies and everything and there's
just so much to get into so let's jump
right in
you want to ride it tetsuo all right
let's hit it
katura otomo i'm going to ruin his name
i apologize
his drawings you know are just painfully
good it inspires the matrix and
cyberpunk and you know in a thousand
things it's just
stunningly animated the classic japanese
animation you'll see a close-up of their
face
and just their mouths are moving but he
brought in
animating the characters on ones
if you want it so bad then steal one
yourself there's 24 drawings a second
which adds that smoothness it's fully
articulated when they talk
there's a cheat an animation when you're
working with animals you know we don't
know how a cartoon elephant
actually moves because there is no
cartoon elephants but when you're
animating a human being
everybody knows how human beings move
and so
that fall lands and it bounces and
scrapes and it hurts you know you
feel the cloth scraping against the
ground
[Music]
did he just clap that in his freaking
muscle meet right you know let's talk
about like slow motion okay it's almost
like a
a natural speed ramp anytime something
complicated happens it's almost like
time slows down just for that one moment
even if it's all in within one shot
which then you see them copying
in matrix
zack snyder comes to mind as well
[Music]
technically there's packed in more
drawings to slow the time down
sure it's been done what had been done
before in animation but i'm
gonna go out on the limb and say he came
up with that idea
you know you can see some cheats here if
you look at the motorcycle
motorcycle is one drawing or it's like
two or three drawings and it's just
doing a cycle so it's a loop it's a loop
and
when you're fred flintstone or
scooby-doo anytime they're running
they're using the exact same cycle
but like we're not going anywhere
they're a little bit frowned upon
because it's a little bit of a cheat
also the background is you know
the background is simplified just lines
streaking by and it loops
absolutely well which also some of the
master
shots of those backgrounds are filled
with so much detail that your eye
doesn't really know where to go
but when you simplify it down to speed
lines like this
it pushes everything away and all that
they're concerned about is the screen
direction
part of animation is distracting your
eye
we're not looking at the motorcycle i'm
looking at that guy in the foreground
who's moving in beautiful perspective
so how the heck are they getting that
light bloom effect that's like overlaid
on top of the motorcycle or is that like
after the fact are they cutting through
or
not the trails but the bloom right yeah
the bloom and the trail let's talk about
both
so back in the day when it was filmed on
the camera
the box where the drawings went on was
also a light table those bloom effects
are hand-drawn elements and then they're
hand animating that trail
then what they would do is they would
paint it in reverse so it would just be
a black image with the hole exposed they
would shoot the
light through the light table into the
camera and it would over expose a little
bit
and it would create that glow effect so
cool
[Music]
so this was the first animation
ever yeah windsor mckay who was a
newspaper comic artist
he is tracing the background on each of
the drawings
the way animation works is it's on
layers you know it's kind of like
photoshop where there's a foreground
element
a middle ground a background and all of
that and you draw them on separate
layers
because you want them moving at
different times but he wasn't able to do
that so with each one of these drawings
he's going in and painstakingly tracing
background
oh my goodness how long do you think
this would have taken him oh
i'm sure we can find out but i'm gonna
guess it's probably over a year to make
this film
that's pretty insane to think about yeah
there's a lot of other things that you
can really see the
birth of there's some real fundamental
principles of animation which are weight
and gravity and follow-through and he's
hitting him you know the dinosaur has
a feel of weight when you get into
animation the first
assignments that you get are a bouncing
ball
a walk cycle and picking up a heavy
object
and it starts you on your fundamentals
of how to animate
a scene so here we've got our ball it's
heading down so that would be my second
drawing
now in timing the closer the drawings
are
to each other the slower it moves the
farther they apart
the faster it moves so here our bar
comes in it's heading towards the ground
then it hits the ground and it squatches
then it starts to bounce and
stretch up and if you watch animation
the whole character will stretch up and
you get this feel
then you know it's bouncing up then i
reach the apex of
the arc and then it starts to slow down
and then speed up again and then bam hit
again
this is timing physics everything there
obviously
aren't dinosaurs to study so he's making
this up
but he's probably looked at footage of
elephants the other early person that's
credited at the beginning of animation
is a photographer named edward
mulbridge who created these still
cameras and they would
run animals in front of the still
cameras and you get to see
the motion of the horse or the person
running so whether you're
doing vfx or whether you're animating
something reference
always got to go back to that ref hey
guys we just crossed 4 million
subscribers
what yes
that's awesome thanks to all of you for
subscribing so we're only
999 000 subscribers away from 5 million
let's do it
consider subscribing early on in my
career i got the chance to work with
chuck jones
and maurice noble who were two of the
warner brothers director and art
director
chuck jones took all of us young
animators and he said let's watch
the general together
he talked about how when they were
boarding the famous warner brothers
shorts what's operdoc and
duck rabbit duck what you're trying to
get to is
where you can tell the story completely
visual
and then the dialogue just acts as
boosting up the character
another principle in animation is a
thing called silhouette value
the idea is you could take your
animation fill it in with black
and all of the storytelling detail will
actually read as a silhouette yeah you
got like the silhouette of a dark cannon
in the bright field behind it
right so if you watch him he's playing
off of the canon
he's lighting it in a way where you can
see exactly what's going on you know
he's using the negative space behind
there
you have no confusion about what's about
to happen to him the big thing
with watching buster keaton and charlie
chaplin is
the visual storytelling animation is a
visual medium something
recent would be like the first 10
minutes of up which completely plays
visually and
you know makes you bawl your brains out
you know so
what happens in animation is kind of two
schools of animation
start to get born right at the beginning
one that
observes and emulates real life and that
would be the disney school where he was
studying animals and studying
you know human beings and he had his
artist really getting in there
and trying to figure this out then max
fleischer who kind of came from more of
a surreal point of view
he was less interested in real life and
kind of had the idea well
we're working in animation and in
animation you can do anything
so it's like there are no limits yeah
he's not walking like a real human being
he's kind of moving to the music
you know his lips are kind of got this
beautiful kind of lyrical
whistle going on
that bridge between reality-based
animation
and surreal carries out for the rest of
the history of animation
this is something that like always blows
my mind like with any medium when
somebody makes something like this
where it's really without any precursor
the look of these animals the way their
eyes are drawn the goofy physics and
noodly arms and now this is one of like
the defining styles of animation that
stuck with us for
a century
maybe you know the answer to this but
why do the characters wear those white
gloves
well there is an element to these
caricatures that are minstrel show
where they're caricaturing black people
you can see the black face and
the white gloves there's a whole history
with jazz and these cartoons are very
jazz influenced again these are guys
from new york
jazz was very subversive music at the
time it was born
originally from slave music and then it
was a way for
repressed black people to create their
own art the subtext to the cartoon is
do you want to join the kkk i know it
sounds really intense but it is do you
want to be a member do you want to be a
member
oh jeez and bimbo is no no i won't i
won't
it's a subversive way to fight against
racism with an early medium it's really
interesting wow
that's fascinating like all that
historical context just gets lost when
you're watching this as a kid and she's
like it's cartoon animals
right yeah if there's ever time to like
talk about that stuff and bring it up
it's kind of now
you know it's fascinating to know the
history of it and you know what's
influencing these designs that
in a way i think a lot of people just
take for granted it's shameful
but it is there wouldn't be modern
animation without
these influences to draw from you know
you have to you have to go through these
things
yeah i mean entertainment and art's
going to reflect the
society and the times that it's created
in both the good and the bad
it's also dark you know i love
children's book authors like raul dahl
or dr seuss there's a darkness to their
stories what they're doing is
they're scaring kids into remembering a
lesson
do you guys have any examples of bad
animation
because i'd personally love to see it
leave a comment down below letting us
know and
we'll break it down on the show
[Music]
been a long time since i've seen this
film i definitely remember the pink
elephant scene
that's like a dumbo
[Music]
dumbo nevermind see it's been a long
time
come on let's go and poke somebody in
the nose why not just for the fun of it
okay
[Music]
wow look at all that detail work
remember for a long time when i was
young i couldn't figure out why the
backgrounds were always painted so
nicely but the parts that would move
would always be flat colored right yeah
so the backgrounds are painted in
watercolor the native american
is painting and then the arms are
animated elements
the artistry at disney studios at this
point had become
so masterful that they were really able
to use
the gravity to tell the story of a
wooden boy
in cartoon form and if you watch the top
of his hair when he moves
the hair is following through and it
gives you a context to these characters
they feel
solid in that world that they're they're
real and they
have come to life what's going on
i imagine it's very hard to communicate
that inertia through
hand-drawn animation because not only
are you looking backwards at the motion
but you're kind of also looking forward
to the motion and drawing almost like
different things in different stages of
motion
absolutely there is a lot of physics and
math involved in animation there's a
science
element to animation which is exactly
what you're talking about it's thinking
ahead
to an action and a reaction is going to
happen
the boys they're all donkeys oh you too
so is the gravity in the motion what
you're checking when you're like
flipping between
your current drawing and the previous
drawing so back in the day when we'd
work on paper it was actually you were
able to look at five drawings
when you start a scene you're doing the
key poses of the scenes
and i'm going to rough out those four
drawings once i've got those four
drawings working then i'm going to start
figuring out the drawings that go in
between those drawings and that's again
your math
there's another term in animation it's
called an s-curve all organic things
flow in an
organic way the physical element of
animation is artistically figuring out
where to put those
in between to create that snap and that
weight
that's great insight that's so cool hey
guys
it's me jake i've traveled across the
space time continuum to arrive at a new
couch in a new location for those of you
who don't know
corridor digital is a video content
company that has been making videos for
10 years on the internet
how do we do that with puget systems
computers and that's why today's sponsor
is very near and dear to our heart they
are a small team based out of puget
sound washington
they build custom workhorses for
professional creators or people who are
looking to break into the professional
game
this is not your average dude you're
getting a dell okay this is
high-end high quality stuff we're
talking and the way that they ensure
that process
is not only by making sure that they
have top
parts for everything they put into a
machine but also the best thing about
puget and the thing that we love about
them the most as creators
you call them up you tell them what it
is you do and they will build one
to spec at the cost that you need kit it
out with
all the bells and whistles all the bio
settings all the tweaking
that's necessary to do that job we have
peace of mind in knowing
that they have the best customer service
they know exactly our machines
and if any time something goes wrong
with them we've got them
right there to help but anyways if you
guys are serious
about breaking into a professional
creative career or you're already in a
professional creative career
consider puget systems just head on over
to pugetsystems.com that's
p-u-g-e-t systems.com tell them corridor
digital senior or just click the link in
the description of this video
so huge thanks to them once again and uh
back to the video
i'm gonna teleport now again
thank you guys so much for watching this
was really fun breaking this down for
the first time thank you eric for coming
out
we have a ton of things to break down
that we didn't get to
on this episode and i know you guys have
some really fun ideas as well so please
leave a comment down below letting us
know what cool animation scenes we need
to break down
so we can get eric back and do another
one of these episodes if you guys like
eric and you want to follow his work
then you can go over to his youtube
channel and check him out the link is
down below